e
inédite, nous dit Normand
Grondin.
- L'hiver approche et, avec lui,
une nouvelle menace so
la forme d'un cocktail inédit
de virus respiratoires :
CO
syncytial, que nos voisins
américains ont déjà surnommé
la triple épidémie.
Le virus syncytial,
un virus commun, mais qui
est parfois popopopopopopopopop,
fait un retour en force
dans les centres pédiatriques
nord-américains après une pause
pand
Dr ANTONIO D'ANGELO, pédiatre
urgentiste, CHU Sainte-Justine
- Cette année, c'est
particulièrement difficile
été exposés à ce virus-là,
donc ils sont plus malades,
ils ont plus de difficulté
à développer l'immunité parce
encore. Donc, ça prend plus de
temps, ils ont plus de chances
de développer des complicatons
de ce virus-là.
elle, survient au même moment,
du jamais-vu, et on ignore
encore quelle sera l'efficacité
du vaccin grippal qu'on a
En plus, et surtout,
il y a les nouveaux
sous-variants d'Omicron.
Trois d'entre eux ont occasionne
et se déploient maintenant
ailleurs dans le monde.
Aujourd'hui, ils représentent
17 % des nouveaux cas-U-U-U-U-U,
19 % en France, 4 % au Québec
et, en moyenne, leur nombre
double chaque semaine.
À ce rythme, on croitdododododos
les palmarès de la COVID
en Europe et en Amérique
d'ici les Fêtes.
Heureusement, même si ces
sous-variants sont extrêmements
fait relativement peu de
dommages là où ils ont frappé.
Dr ALAIN LAMARRE, virologue
Inst. nat de rech. scientifique
qui devrait quand même
nous protéger de...
si ce n'est de l'infection,
ça va quand même assez bien
et des risques de complications.
- La vaccination, disent
les experts, reste encore
se protéger contre cette
potentielle triple épidémie.
Ici Normand Grondin,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.